welcome fellow hunters I hope you're
ready to discuss the new prospects for
experienced monster slayers now you can
specialise and choose to be you're an
old fashioned hunter a former church or
an arcane mechanic you can reach as high
as level 60 while battling through brand
new adventures there are over 200 unique
skills at your disposal and this time
it's not only about killing monsters
someone has to take responsibility for
the Borgo vien resistance and this job
needs an experienced professional like
you as their commander you can give
orders to through your resistance
captains and send them on various
missions as they progress with their
quests they gather experience and
collect loot a hunter with so many
assignments needs a journal to keep
track of his quests while you're
handling the management of the
resistance you will embark on different
missions we're at war
so you will often be called upon to
defend your underground lair you can
easily build various traps with devious
upgrades that will defend your lair
against your hordes of enemies but don't
forget that you're a commander now you
can always send out your soldiers to
deal with these threats it's time to
spice up your arcane knowledge with
runecrafting which allows you to enhance
or build powerful new equipment at the
same time enchanting has become even
more powerful during your adventures
you'll find a new Guardian for your
secret lair it's called the Chimera a
powerful beast from the ink that you can
summon in dire situations you can send
the beast on hunting trips to collect
valuable treasure but beware you should
never let it get hungry any
self-respecting hunter enjoys the sight
of his hard-earned trophies they also
grant you unique bonuses but beware
each trophy gives some advantage to your
enemies as well a team of hunters is an
unstoppable force of nature team up with
your friends to defend Borgo via in one
of the two multiplayer modes co-op
campaign or the Battle Royale
Peevy
so the incredible adventures continue I
have trust in you my fellow hunters I
know that he will defend or go via from
the dangers of mad science good hunting